okay so this is the original screen that
you'll start with what if you've
installed noobs and here you can pick
any operating system you want Arch Linux
we've got openelec Panora time and now
I've never even heard of this RISC OS
rasp emc don't know anything
they've got raspbian which is like the
recommended operating system
raspy ins really easy to use I would say
and so I think for the person this video
will go over that but if you're used to
a Linux operating system and you want to
use a lot of things that are like
intended for Linux and Arch Linux might
be a better idea for you but anyway
we're going to download raspy so it's
just saying that oh this is gonna
overwrite everything if you have
anything and that's okay we're hey guys
and we'll begin your writing of the
image to the SD card so basically what
this is doing is it's saving you the job
of lighting that image to the SD card
because originally you would have had to
learn how to light the image you still
do that if you want but this is so much
easier and then what makes it really
nice is you can since there are so many
operating systems like if you're like me
is that well [ __ ] I don't know which one
I want to use I kind of want to like
look through them on and decide you know
and so this makes are really easy to do
that plus like there's going to be times
where you want a specific program with
your Raspberry Pi and you'll be like
you'll need a specific operating system
so maybe somebody is loaded purely for
raspbian right you don't really know
until you start figuring out what you
want to do is I think a lot of people
buy the rest very PI and they have no
idea what they even want to do with it
they just buy it it's like a fun little
thing right it's a toy it's exactly what
it is is a toy so anyway I'm gonna pause
the video while we're doing this there's
some information that it gives you as is
loading your operating system so you
know at least there's something you can
do while you watch basically the most
important thing you want to know at
least at this step is if you want to
access that menu ever again
because naturally it will just boot
straight to your desktop if you want it
again on startup hold down the shift key
and then I'll give you the option to
change your operating system applied it
will overwrite anything that you had so
far so any programs etc there on the SD
card if you have programs on a USB Drive
right so much of it the image applied
successfully you'll get the image
applied successfully Mesut here and
you'll just need to hit OK and then
what's going to do is it's gonna boot
the line and do some more commands for
you I think we'll just keep it running I
believe it's actually a pretty quick
process here so just speed up the video
if it takes a while so the next thing
that will happen eventually is you'll go
it'll give you a screen up here lets you
choose a few options as far as like hoop
options are concerned I like I think
it's kind of like BIOS for your
raspberry PI's a good way to think of it
and so you can decide whether you want
to boot to the smash berry pie pie us
every time or if you want to go to the
desktop so you can change that really
simply there's a few other things that
you can do okay so here we are in our in
our BIOS so you can expand the file
system I guess this is just a good way
to make sure that every high your space
on the SD card is getting used but
around the keyboard over to these
options here you can change the user
password right now the user that's
interesting oh I'm sorry okay I was
reading PI I was like that's not true
anyway the the default username and
password if you don't happen to go
through this is the username is PI the
password is raspberry for now I'm just
going to leave it like that enable Boop
to desktop this is where you can make it
Desktop instead of the command line but
I kind of think it's best to go straight
to the command line first
internationalization options I don't
even read this bucket - just for a
region and language and all this the
camera this is just to work with that
camera there's a Raspberry Pi camera
using that add to rest right I don't
know what this is some sort of tracking
that for us berry pies I don't know here
you can start to overclock we'll do some
some of that in another video
advanced options we'll talk about those
probably another video and then this is
some more information regarding the
Raspberry Pi otherwise just hit finish
and you will be sent to your command
language is beginning right here and so
actually the first thing that we're
gonna do to start your desktop you
wanted to say start sorry let me sit
down so you want to say start and then
just hit eggs and like that will send
you to your desktop now when we finally
get there you see we've got this
beautiful background looks yummy and you
shouldn't you know feel fairly
comfortable with this desktop it looks
it's hello bar down here like a start
bar initially whenever I was running it
this was just like a total black box it
doesn't have any bars or anything I was
like what's going on here like some sort
of image is dead but no this is actually
like your running process is and it
looks like this is a shutdown or I guess
it's a log down I'm not really sure if
it would shut us down or not but I'll
show you guys how to shut down in a
minute
but anyway coming like pre-installed on
here you've got all kinds of fun stuff
this is a way to get to your terminal
really easily without logging out and
then you've also got Python 3 and then
Python 2 7 both are installed on this
system so if you're familiar with either
of those coding languages you can use
them both on here which is pretty cool
that it's like already on the system
I clicked them both you can like see
everything it just goes crazy if you
like click something you'll be like
clicking it you
won't come up instantly if you've you
know if you're used to a fast computer
won't come up instantly and you'll click
it again and again you'll be like what's
up hi frozen and then like they'll all
pop up like five minutes later and
you're like oh damn anyway so yeah so
you got to seven and python three point
two point three on here so pretty epic
to have them both on there for you
there's also scratch it recommended that
you use scratch if you watched all the
information was giving you what you were
downloading but honestly I mean maybe I
assume most people watching my tutorials
are somewhat familiar with programming
but is this like I just don't know what
to do is this okay so maybe someone can
tell me pretty supposed to do you know
there's like some sort of online
tutorial for this but this looks really
confusing to me anyway